so once we learn our Y we have the
opportunity to apply it in all different
parts of our lives so you for jobs for
example we want to work for a company
that our Y complements the companies why
were more likely to fit we've more
likely to feel like we belong it goes
with our friends - believe it or not we
do it inherently you know there's lots
of nice people in the world but we're
not friends with everybody in the world
we're friends with the people that we
share values with but sometimes we have
people in our lives let's be honest that
we may have a good time with them but
it's not a deep meaningful relationship
knowing your Y actually helps you
understand why the deep meaningful
relationships are the deep meaningful
relationships it's a new way of of
understanding the value of people in our
lives
you know how trust builds but it's it's
it's the opportunity is to use it to
find things that are more likely to
produce joy success focus inspiration
and fulfillment in the decisions we make
the books we read the the people we keep
in our lives where we invest our time
and where we invest our energy you know
it's we we get a limited amount of time
in the day in a limited amount of years
on the planet it's the great equalizer
whether we're rich or poor we all have
24 hours in a day and the idea is to to
get as much out of those hours and as
much out of those years as possible
[Music]